Did.
They were going to start talking about music of the Baroque period.
1600 to 1750 exemplified by js.
Bach today will be the first of two presentations about the music of Bach.
One today dealing with box vocal music.
The other coming in sections.
Yes,
we have sections on Thursday,
Friday and Monday having to do with the instrumental music of Js Bach.
So we're going to start now with Baroque music and Bach and a word first about
box.
Uh,
biography bock came from a very long line of musicians in deed 10 generations of
box.
We're musicians goes back to old Veit Bach in the 16th century and continues
generation after generation into the 19th century in the area in which Bach was
born,
this small town of Eisenach,
you can see the town's name up there and the date in which you was born,
1685 in this area of Thuringia,
the region which Eisenach sits the word Bach was eponymous.
In other words,
a Bach simply met a musician,
a musician,
just like we have the word Kleenex,
for example,
or we have the word xerox that begin to take on the connotations of an entire
class.
So it'd be a Bach in that area was to be a musician.
Johann Sebastian Bach was simply the most talented of this long lived clan of
musicians from the age of nine Js Bach was orphan.
Both his parents had died by that time.
So it was raised for the most part by his older brother,
Johann Christoph Bock,
who was a student of our Johann puck.
A bell.
So there is this connection between the box and a PA cowbell and for the most
part,
js Bach was a self taught.
How did he teach himself music?
Well,
he copied music.
He copied music for two reasons.
One,
to learn the musical style and to,
to get music because you simply couldn't go to a photocopying machine.
Uh,
and copy this,
the music of Corolla or the music of [inaudible].
Uh,
you had to copy it down yourself by hand.
You couldn't go to a music store and buy edited additions because for the most
part,
that didn't exist so much more of,
it was simply music copied by one musician after the next.
So Bach learned his craft by copying literally Corelli and we have run into
Corelli.
Of course,
anybody remember a piece by Corelli that we perform?
Frederick La Folia excellent.
Uh,
and he copied Vivaldi.
What's some of all these most famous composition Frederick again,
the four seasons.
So,
uh,
so he copied that and he also copied a,
some other can charity Grossi of,
of Vivaldi,
uh,
oftentimes surreptitiously,
by moonlight when he was supposed to be in bed box devotion to his profession
was legendary when he was a young man.
He sort of went AWOL from his first job and walk from the town of Orange Dot,
which you see up there,
a walk from orange.in the center part of Germany,
all the way up to the Hanseatic city of Oulu back on the North Sea up there,
a distance of about 250 miles in order to be able to sit at the feet of a very
famous organist and composer there and Lubeck.
And then he walked back.
It would be like one of us wanting to learn something from a congressman or
something and walking to from new haven to Washington DC in back in his day,
Bach was legendary.
Not so much as a composer,
oddly enough,
but as what?
What was Bach known for in his day?
We touched on this before,
Angela.
He was an organist.
Okay.
So he was an organist.
He was the v Great Virtuoso organist of central northern Germany,
uh,
in this period.
Now we have met a Oregon piece of Bach before.
What was that?
Uh,
name Michael.
Mitch.
Okay.
Yes.
What was that please?
G minor feud.
Can you sing any of it?
Good.
Anybody seeing any of it?
Hey,
we got some takers down here.
Kristen [inaudible] together.
A Duet gentlemen please.
Excellent.
Oh Wow.
Bravo.
Okay.
Hmm.
Mm.
That's sort of the key that they sang it.
And we'll come back to that idea in just a minute because I found myself
tripping over that fugue subject.
And another one that I want to talk about this morning is,
I was trying to think through these.
There's another famous piece,
Oregon piece of Bach that we might have heard recently.
Do we have the Takata queued up there?
It should be track one.
Let's listen to a Toccata by Bach written in orange dot early in his career.
Whoa.
Where did that come from?
That's,
Oh,
I know it's in the mission
they were in,
they were in the bay.
We lost the CD this morning.
So it's sitting in the machine.
How interesting.
Sometimes a,
our CD player eats our machine for days on days on end and then only belatedly
spits it back out.
So do we have that?
Uh,
okay.
We don't have that cute.
I'm sorry,
but you've probably heard it at the concert the other day.
T team.
It's a big Oregon piece in d minor kind of spooky music that begins every
Halloween show.
Well,
that's more organ music by J Bach.
We may be able to,
to resurrect that.
After a while,
we'll,
we'll find out,
uh,
and again,
a piece that he composed as a young man here in the town of Orange Dot.
Roughly 1705 or so.
So there he is a first job,
uh,
and we won't say fresh out of college because Bach did not go to college,
but he went to a very,
uh,
hike,
standing prep school in the northern part of Germany,
just graduated,
has his first job at orange dot.
Let's take a look at a raw wool.
Here is the picture of our great men.
But let's go on to our first,
uh,
real slide there.
And I think everybody see that.
Okay.
That's the organ in the church had orange dot where Bach worked.
Uh,
the Oregon is still there.
the,
the essential parts of the pipes and all are still there.
That's the very organ that Bach play,
but they've sort of modernized it over the centuries and they took out the
original console.
So Rachel,
if we could have the next slide please.
And there is the console.
This is the kind of the central processing unit,
if you will,
for a box Oregon.
So you can see,
does that look like a big Oregon or a small organ to you by our standards?
Kind of on the smallest side.
They were bigger ones actually,
uh,
up,
up to,
up to the north.
Uh,
but you can see here some of you did that extra credit credit project on the
Oregon,
two keyboards and a pedal board down here to be played of obviously with the
feet.
And what do you suppose these things are working all around it?
What,
what would we call those?
We're going to pull one of those,
uh,
stop.
Okay.
And it brings into play and extra rank of pipes,
pipes of a particular sound.
And we have this expression,
oh,
I'm going to pull out all the stops.
Well,
of course,
that has to do with Oregon technology.
So this is box,
uh,
the console ineffective box,
original Oregon.
A Bach eventually left orange dot and moved on to the larger city of Weimar,
uh,
where he stayed.
As you can see there from 1708 to 17 seven,
uh,
1717 and he functioned as an organist and a court,
a musician there in 17,
17,
he decided to leave that position in Weimar and move on to another town curtain.
And the Duke of Weimar Pr,
Duke Ville helm summarily had Bach thrown in jail.
Bach was thrown in jail for a month,
sat in jail,
languish in jail.
We think he started the well tempered clavier a while in jail.
Why did the Duke have box thrown in jail?
Any ideas?
Well,
he hadn't obtained a release from the Duke.
And this tells us something about the status of musicians in the 18th century.
There were little better than indentured servants,
no such thing as free agency here,
not like baseball players or whatever.
Today.
Uh,
if you wanted to take another position,
you had to get your present employer to say,
okay,
it's all right if you go,
imagine that today you want to quit your job and move on to a better job.
Well,
you can't leave until the present boss says you can go.
But that was the case.
And Bach had violated that modus operandi and there he languished in jail for a
month.
Finally,
the Duke of Weimar,
uh,
relented and off Bach and his family went to the town of Curtin.
Let's take a look at the next slide please.
The town of Curtin,
um,
again,
sort of central Germany.
This is an engraving of the mid 17th century and we can see here the court
building of complex plexes where Bach worked there in the center.
Now we're going to go to the front of that next slide.
Uh,
as it stands today is rather heavily damaged after communist occupation after
World War Two,
uh,
rather,
not in the best state of repair.
You go inside the court yard there a next slide please.
Going in and you can see it's something of a mess because they are fixing up
that room and indeed half fixed up that room up above.
Let's have the,
the next slide please.
A and here is that room up above the,
so now crystal room of the palace at Curtin and this was where Bach performed.
And when you go to sections this week,
you will watch a wonderful video of a performance of the Bach Brandenburg
Concerto number five,
perform right in this hall.
You'll see those same windows there.
This is Bach's music,
uh,
performed,
performed in the environment for which Bach had created in 1723.
Bach moved again,
he was an aggressive,
uh,
um,
ambitious,
uh,
person js Bach.
He moved this time to the city of Leipzig,
Leipzig,
a little bit to the south of Curtin and he spent the rest of his career in
Leipzig.
He moved to Leipzig in 1723 for two reasons and we'll come back to those two
reasons.
But while I have this slide up here,
let's just put this in context a little bit.
You can see where Berlin is there.
You can see where Lubeck is,
where he walked all the way at the top.
This is central Germany here,
and these towns aren't too far apart.
Here's curtain.
Here's Leipzig.
So 1723,
he goes to Leipzig and he goes there for two reasons.
One next slide.
One,
because his family will be given by the standards of the time,
rather large corridors here.
Actually by our standards,
they were very small.
900 square feet.
Buck ultimately had 20 children and they were living in 900 square feet.
Ask Yourself,
do you know how many square feet are in your parents' apartment or home?
A lot more than 900.
But that would,
this was thought to be big digs back in the 18th century in these cities that
were in case by military fortresses.
In any event,
we see box working here and living area right here in this building.
And I want you to count the number of stories because it will become important
later on.
One,
two,
three.
And then the roof begins.
Uh,
and I also want you to,
uh,
it's hard to see in the slide,
but there's a group of choir boys walking out here.
How do I know their choir boys?
Cause they're arranged by height.
Ever look at choir boys.
That's how they arrange them when they walk in procession,
the young kids first,
the older ones,
uh,
towards the back.
We'll come back to that point,
uh,
in,
in just a,
just a minute.
Um,
another reason Bach moved to Leipzig was it was a university town so he could
get a free university education for his numerous sons.
What about his numerous daughters?
Did they get a free education at the university?
No,
because women did not go to the university in this period.
The first woman to receive a degree,
a college degree in a Western University,
uh,
was a woman enrolled in philosophy at the University of Padua and 1676,
1676.
So it would be unprecedented really.
I mean,
there was one precedent,
a inbox day for women to go to university.
It was assumed that just the men would go to university.
In any event,
let's talk about box standing here in the town of Leipsic.
Bach had to petition for this job.
He wanted this job because it had these advantages as mentioned.
Uh,
and he was not the first choice of the town council of Leipsic.
there was another composer who was their first choice.
Georg Fidi him,
he declined the position.
They offered it to somebody else named [inaudible].
He couldn't get a release from his employer so he couldn't take it.
And so as the town minutes,
uh,
of the,
town council,
the of the town council say,
since,
uh,
good musicians can't be had,
we'll have mediocre ones will have to suffice.
And they turn at that point to Bach,
uh,
which I guess calls us to ask,
how many misjudgments are we making in our lives?
May Be,
uh,
Aja doesn't realize that sitting right next to him,
Chris,
there is really a genius and,
and we should pay more attention to how many geniuses they're sort of sneaking
around in our midst on recognized today.
Anyway,
Bach was anything other than the groaned [inaudible] east.
Uh,
when he arrived in Leipzig,
uh,
here,
I've made some xeroxes out of my book called the Bach reader.
When Barack got there,
he had to take an oath of office.
He had to swear to do the following.
One,
I shall set the boys a shiny example of honest and retiring manner of life,
serve the school industriously and instruct the boys conscientiously to bring
the music on all the principal churches of the town into good estate to the best
of my ability.
Three show the honorable and most wise counsel.
All proper respect and obedience and so on.
It goes,
here are a few more things.
Faithfully instruct the boys not only in vocal music but also an instrumental
music.
Andy had to teach them Latin as well.
Uh,
arrange the music that it shall not last too long,
ah,
shall be of such a nature as not to make an operatic impression but rather
insight the listeners to devotion.
So they didn't want Bach's music to go on too long,
which is very important.
And they didn't want it to be very operatic.
They wanted sort of conservative music there.
Uh,
here's a number 12 not to go out of town without the permission of the honorable
burgermeister a number 13,
always walk as far as possible with the boys at,
at funerals.
So Bach here in Leipzig is sort of a glorified scoutmaster he's,
he's not this kind of 19th century image of the genius or the of the globe
artist as mentioned.
Uh,
okay.
The point being,
once again,
the Bach in his day was recognized and valued not so much as a composer,
but as a performer.
Well,
what was the matter with Bach's music?
Why did they want already at the outset here sort of clipping his wings,
telling him what style not to write in?
Well,
Bob had this proclivity for writing music that's very sort of rigid,
very chromatic,
very contrapuntal and very long.
And it is long and contract portal as we will be seeing in particularly in,
in sections,
uh,
this,
coming,
uh,
week.
If we compare for example,
to can charity Grossi the first movement of,
of Ah,
of evolve these spring concerto,
it lasts three minutes and 10 seconds.
Bach writes a first movement of a concerto.
Grosso.
You're going to watch a video of it.
It runs for nine minutes and 10 seconds.
So it's three times as long,
three times as,
as dense in a way.
Um,
okay.
Let's,
uh,
let's go on to talk about the kinds of things that Bach composed here and for
that we'll take,
take a look at,
uh,
at the board.
Um,
box works.
Some of these we've talked about already,
preludes and fugues for Harpsichord or keyboard,
the well tempered clavier.
We've talked about the g minor Oregon few.
We've,
we can talk about the art of the fugue.
Uh,
let's around.
Well,
let's have the next slide.
Uh,
I think I've got a slide of that here.
no wrong piece.
Okay.
Sorry.
Uh,
this is the Bach Brandenburg.
I brought in the wrong slide.
I'm sorry.
Uh,
but the art of Fugue is an interesting composition that a Bach wrote v very much
toward the end of his life.
Sonatas for flutes and violin.
Viola,
a dance suites for orchestra.
You may know the air on the g string.
Beautiful,
beautiful s Solo Violin writing there with Basso continuo underneath solo
concertos for violin and Harpsichord.
Uh,
the um,
can charity Grossi that we'll be talking about the Brandenburg concertos.
We'll be working with number five.
Then he wrote a lot of religious vocal music.
The B minor mass.
I was playing parts of the sunk two of the B minor mass.
Uh,
when we,
when we came in,
uh,
Linda,
this is going to really mess things up.
Do we know what,
try where we have that a sunk twos where the Bach B minor mass massive is track
10.
If you can get to the CD,
let's just listen to a little bit of,
this is on the fly this morning,
but let's,
let's just listen to a bit of the sunk twos of the B minor mass to give you a
sense of the,
the,
the monumental quality that Bach can create.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
okay.
Pretty impressive stuff,
but it goes on for a long time and it's filled with,
with imitation and fugal subjects that recombine in different kinds of
permutations can be inverted and go backwards and forwards and upside down.
Uh,
and this is what Bach would do if somebody would write a,
uh,
a set of variations that had 10 variations in it.
He would write a set of variations with 20 variations.
If somebody would write one cannon,
he would write a 10 canons as he does,
for example,
in the Goldberg variations.
Whatever he did,
he sorta prosecuted maniacally.
And what he ended up with,
with stuff that's,
that's very dense,
very compact,
is really the best sort of craftsmanship.
But it's not necessarily the most sort of popular music in,
in that regard.
But as you hear heard,
it can be,
uh,
very,
grand and quite a spectacular as we heard from the song tos of the B minor mass
there.
When Bob arrived in Leipzig,
it was a town of 35,000 in,
was one of the biggest in Germany.
Does that sound like a big town to you?
35 south thousand?
No,
I mean,
hand in probably has 35,000 people living in,
but this was a big city in inbox day.
Um,
and he was called there to run a music,
uh,
for really for all of the Lutheran churches in that town.
Now that we're talking here,
uh,
Leipzig,
which is not far from Wittenberg where,
uh,
Martin Luther,
was active.
So we're talking about kind of the,
the,
the home ground of Lutheranism here and Leipzig enjoyed complete freedom of
religion.
Uh,
you can attend any church accorded,
this was all Christianity.
You can attend any church that you wished,
any church that you wish there were a dozen or so of them in the city.
The only kicker was that they were all Lutheran churches.
It goes this Lutheran church or that Lutheran Church,
whatever when you want,
but they were all Lutheran churches.
Okay.
So box job was to organize the music for these churches,
particularly the principal church,
which was this Saint Thomas Church.
And what he wrote for this Saint Thomas Church was this thing called the
Cantata.
What's a Cantata?
Well,
literally it's a sung thing as opposed to a sonata.
So nata sounded thing.
So this is a sung thing.
What can we say about the Cantatas that Bach Road?
How would we summarize them?
Well,
they are multi movements.
Uh,
recitatives Aria Chorus,
multimedia movements.
They go on for about 25 to 30 minutes.
They are religious,
uh,
in,
um,
subject matter.
And of course they are written in the German language.
And Bach wrote about 300 of these cantatas.
He wrote them in cycles of 50.
When he arrived there in 17.
23 starts writing one cantata for each Sunday.
The end of the,
at the end of the a year,
he's got about 50 of these things.
Next year he starts all over again.
So we ended up with about 300 cantatas.
Then he got exhausted from the process and stopped about 17,
29,
1730 or so.
Now on the board up here,
you see the layout of a typical,
a Cantata,
uh,
it is vocat hour lunch dish Dima arise,
a voice is calling.
And here's,
here's,
I hope you can see this.
Okay.
Here's how it shakes down.
We have seven the movements in this [inaudible] seven movements.
Um,
and they are arranged chorus.
Then recitatives what's a recitatives somebody tell us what the rest of the t
is.
We haven't talked about it,
but maybe you know from other context.
Uh,
Jacob.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's not much music,
more,
more sort of spoken dialogue accompanied a little bit by a Baso continue,
uh,
Baso continuum.
Anybody tell me from the reading when a baso continuum is,
I think if you look on your text and about page one 14,
you'll find a discussion of it.
But at Bosco continual is,
um,
an ensemble that plays a baseline and because a number of instruments are
involved in,
it'd be the left hand of the Harpsichord,
maybe a cello,
maybe also a bassoon,
two,
three instruments playing the baseline.
It makes for a very heavy,
very powerful baseline.
And this is something that is typical of baroque music.
So a recitatives will be a company and indeed all the Arias will be accompanied
by Baso.
Continue with the choral stuff,
will be contempt ended by Bosco continuum.
Continuum is just always going.
So it's a strong base that's always going.
It's different from the boss.
So ostinato because what happens in a boss?
No ostinato
young,
it keeps repeating over and over and over again.
So a Baso Ostinato would be of a particular kind of Baso continuum.
I'm kind of a species of Baso continuum,
but Bosco continuum of based,
it's always going on and is very strong.
So we'd have sort of spoken dialogue with a strong base,
then an Aria,
and I'm going to say something about this,
these Arias in this period,
they are dot Capo Arias in the baroque period.
What does a de Capo Aria mean?
Anybody peeked ahead and that are in discussions around pages one 51 60 or so in
the text or know that from,
uh,
other contexts.
What would it dot Capo Aria be?
Well,
literally.
Dot.
Capo.
And it sounds like a film score.
The Capo or something.
It means the head guy,
the head guy,
or in this case,
the beginning of the music.
The head of the music means you take it from the beginning of the music.
So you do one,
a section and a section,
and then you have a contrasting section,
and then you'll get this sign that says d C.
Dot.
Capo.
And then you go back and do the a section all over again.
So what form do we end up with when we have a duck capo orient,
then obviously
turn and reform.
Okay,
so the Arias in here are usually structured in the baroque period,
in a dot.
Capo form.
And then we have the choruses chorus one chorus for chorus seven.
And in each of these choruses we are making use of this thing called a chorale
tune.
A corral tune.
What's a corral?
What's a corral to what corral tune is just what,
uh,
other Christian denominations would call a him or what we here at Yale,
whether we're a Muslim,
whether we're Jewish or,
uh,
whether we're Christian,
we're going to have to sing the,
and so when it goes,
I think it's called Duke Street.
Oh God.
Beneath God.
Above the rising stars die,
exiled father's cross the sea.
It's,
it was actually written here in new haven.
So it's kind of the Yale,
him,
if you will,
or maybe the Yale a chorale.
Um,
so these chorales were sort of old melodies,
old religious melodies.
Some of them worked sort of remakes of Gregorian chants.
The Lutherans just took old Catholic chance and turned them into corral tunes.
Others were newly composed going all the way back to the 16th century.
Martin Luther himself composed a corral tunes.
Anybody name a corral tune or a hymn tune of Martin Luther,
I bet you
tata,
Tata,
Bom,
bom,
bom.
Um,
and by knowing the name of that,
yes.
Uh,
Kristen didn't it?
Okay.
Nice and loud please.
Christian.
Okay.
A mighty fortress is our God.
It's a reformation.
The reformation corral and musicians have used that frequently over the,
over the,
uh,
over the centuries.
Um,
so we're going not going to be working with a mighty fortress.
We're going to be working with a different corral tune,
voc and Alpha root and Judy Stimah,
which was a couple of years old by the time Bob got his hands on it and you have
it here.
So on your sheet,
everybody got the sheet for today?
Maybe I'll turn the lights back on.
Just see a little better.
Yeah,
it's a little better.
How that's even,
so here is a corral to,
and it's in lots of phrases.
Right?
Um,
what about this,
do you think that's a tonal melodies?
Does that sound pretty secure for you or does that sound sort of weird?
Roger,
what do you think
down secure.
It is tonal.
And why would you imagine it sounds secure if you look at the down beat of each
measure,
uh,
almost every measure.
What notes do we have there?
There are notes that form
a triad,
a major triad,
so we mustn't forget all that stuff we studied early on.
So here's Bach or borrowing a corral to that is you is for grounding a major
triad in a big way and uh,
who has to sing this walls and really the full congregation,
everybody has to sing these corral tunes to show that you are a,
in this case,
a good Lutheran I suppose.
Um,
so everybody was be expected to sing them.
And because of that,
they tended to be rather step wise.
So we should all sing this right?
Today we're all going to be good Lutherans,
no matter what our real religion is,
assuming we have a real religion.
So let's,
um,
let's start here and we're just going to sing law.
Here we go.
La,
la,
la.
Okay,
great.
Now this is,
this is not working so well and why is it not working so well?
It's too high.
So what would [inaudible] have done in those days?
The only person here that can sing this is Leah.
Uh,
Linda and Santana.
Cause they're sopranos and I could hear them.
Uh,
but that was about all I could hear.
It's too high.
So what would they have done in box day?
Stop singing.
It had a lightening bolts would come down.
The church is a bad,
I'm not quite sure why they couldn't stop singing it.
They had to transpose it.
Just take it down.
We'll make it lower.
Let's go.
Different key.
Here we go.
Ready?
Sing
la La la.
Rest
louder.
Okay,
we'll stop there.
We'll stop there.
So bucks got this corral and then he's going to do something with it.
Uh,
and what he does is write a first movement.
So that takes us back over here to movement.
One of,
of our,
uh,
chorale.
Um,
we're going to talk now about the text.
Uh,
uh,
with regard to this particular,
um,
chorale.
What's the texts calling about?
Well,
here's what,
here's the translation of it.
Awake.
A voice is calling from the watchman from high in the tower awake Jerusalem.
Midnight is the hour.
They call us with a clarion voice.
Where are the wise virgins?
Get up,
the bridegroom cometh,
stand up and take your lamps,
Aloe Luhya provide yourself for the wedding.
Go.
You must go out,
go forth to meet him.
Um,
now inbox day,
this corral would have been sung.
It's the major musical portion of the Cantata,
which is the major musical portion of the whole service,
which was sung,
right?
The reading of the Gospel.
So they'd come in and there'd be some introductory corrals and prayers and that
kind of thing.
Then they would have a reading of the Gospel of the Gospel,
the,
the thesis of the day.
Now this particular Cantata is written for advent.
So what's advent?
Who can tell me what advent is?
Don't necessarily have,
you know,
Muslim,
Jewish,
Christian,
whatever.
You may probably know what Admin is that is,
okay.
It's the days before Christmas.
So we have the English word adventitious,
something coming,
something about to arrive.
It's the birth of Christ in this particular case.
So it's a,
I think roughly the four weeks before Christmas,
thinking maybe late November,
early December,
up to Christmas.
So,
so that's when this cantata would have been,
uh,
would have been appropriate.
Who'd been sung say the on the Sunday,
the 1st of December,
something,
something like that.
And as I say,
it's preceded by the gospel of the day.
So to get our heads in this,
we have to understand what box message is here.
We have to know what the Gospel is.
So I've asked Chris,
I gave Chris The textbook here.
I put the,
the textbook and ask Christa,
read the Gospel for today.
So sound is stand up and or,
yeah,
you can stand up
Michelle.
Oh good.
I like that.
Nice and loud of the voice.
The Voice of God
took the labs and when forth to meet and
hey,
that's cool.
But the goal
and it was a crime,
behold the bridegroom come out to me and all of those versions of roads and
traffic,
their lists and the coolest set to the wise give us oil.
Arlene's.
But the wise answer it say not sad least there'd be not enough for us.
And the go,
you'd rather to them that set and by yourself and you get to buy the Brian Room.
Okay.
And they got ready,
went in with him to the managers and the door was shut up.
Watch for,
you know,
neither the day nor the hour we're in the sun.
Okay,
excellent.
And then that's the King James version of that.
So the,
the,
the syntax is sometimes difficult in the verbiage is a little bit unexpected
there.
But what does all this mean?
What is this Roger?
Uh,
the second coming of Christ.
Okay.
Uh,
and what are we supposed to do?
We good citizens of Leipzig.
What are we supposed to do?
Great.
The ready get our spiritual house in order because Christ is coming.
So Bach has this idea of this powerful figure coming into the midst of Leipzig,
uh,
and he creates the following kind of music.
We start out here with Dum de Dum,
de Dum,
and then it begins to move a little bit in pitch.
It's a good example of,
of uh,
something that we'll talk about it in a moment,
but if we want to have the sense of the inexorable march of something,
what better way than a repeating baseline.
Then we have a melody begin.
Yeah.
T,
t t t t t t t,
t.
T.
And then we didn't have time.
We have a c mode motive that we want to put up.
Yeah.
T,
t t t t t t t t t t t t t t,
t,
t.
T.
Dumb.
But I'm being,
so when you read your textbook there,
I interpreted this as follows a you will,
you will hear someone saying,
I he me saying that,
uh,
this is,
the inexorable march of the Lord coming to the citizens of Leipzig.
They get very excited and then begin to run in his direction.
Um,
and uh,
this is the,
uh,
you know,
Bach didn't write all this down and kind of interpreting it this way,
but I,
I can't help but think back on the early session that we had talking about the
musical Chicago and that,
uh,
that number in Chicago and uh,
get the,
the gun,
the gun to do that
De de,
De,
de,
de.
De.
It gets faster and faster and the texture gets denser and denser.
Well,
that's exactly what block is doing here.
Whether it's Broadway or box,
the,
the modus operandi is going to be the same.
So let's listen to just a little bit here.
This is the opening movement of box Cantata vocat our fruit punch dish demo.
Okay.
That's
just the opening phrase.
And the crowds coming in with little,
a few goal expositions underneath that who were,
who were coming were sort of this busy counterpoint underneath.
I used to use this as a listening exercise,
but it didn't work.
It was too,
I couldn't get,
the students couldn't respond,
I don't know.
It just was too complex.
And then the way it told me something,
Bach's music is very,
very complex.
So I went on to a,
uh,
I think a more straight forward movement and that's what we're going to do now.
The fourth movement that incorporates the corrals,
we have the,
the corrals,
sort of like the voice of God up here on top.
Let's go onto the fourth movement.
Uh,
that may well recognized as one of box,
most famous compositions.
And I have three questions for you here.
Uh,
what's the base doing?
Yeah.
How many of voices are there?
How many lines strands do here in the texture and where is the corral tune?
Who's singing the corral too?
So this is movement for,
of Cantata vocat out.
Yeah.
Oh,
that's,
and then the Red Tornillo starts again.
This refrain theme starts all over again.
All right,
let's pause it there.
So what kind of base do we have here?
Okay.
Called Walking Bass,
right?
We've talked about that before.
Uh,
and once again,
it gives a very sort of secure a foundation.
So we have a boss,
oh,
continue.
We'll play a walking bass.
Boom.
Okay.
MMM.
Thing like that.
Just going on and on,
sort of with the same note,
values tends to be stepwise.
Have the same note values.
Uh,
what else did we need to know there?
What happened to the corral?
Well,
first of all,
well,
what about the texture?
How many strands did you hear in that texture?
Okay,
Ryan and Nicole,
you want to huddle out there and figure out what the answer to this one is?
What,
what do you think,
Nicole?
How many,
uh,
how many strands?
How many lines did you hear there?
Okay,
well,
we've got the base in there and we had that lovely,
lovely melody.
The Tottenham Pod,
even part in which you have on,
on sheet there.
Uh,
so that's two.
And what was the third one?
Well,
the corral Dune,
your palm palm body,
him.
But what was different about the corral tune this time?
It was easier to hear why?
Because all of the male voices were singing it together in unison.
It wasn't distributed in all of this counterpoint in all of the voices,
all the line,
uh,
all the voices were singing it together.
And if you have this sheet here,
I think the miracle of this particular sheet is that this guy thought I had this
one melody Yadim palm and he said,
Gee Whiz,
you know,
as I went,
Yachty bodied it on bottom,
beat up,
beat up.
I could have that go against this melody.
He,
he thought he had won the Nice Melody and he thought up an even more beautiful
melody that could interweave with his given melody.
So that's the gift here too,
to be able to hear one thing and a size up its implications to know what it
could become.
I guess that's what a great creative artist is all about.
To know what something can become.
All right,
so we have,
uh,
that particular movement and I think that's the basis of your listening
exercise.
22,
uh,
for next time.
Um,
now,
uh,
we're getting toward the end of our hour and I wanted to ask you,
um,
what we're going to do,
two,
two more things.
One,
we're going to come back at the end to the end of the CONTORTA.
Uh,
but I want to ask you a question,
uh,
about,
just try to put yourself in boxing shoes here for the moment.
You got this job as a composer and you've got to generate all this music,
right?
You got to generate 25 to 30 minutes of new music every week.
Well,
that would be like,
all right,
so presumably you get Sunday afternoon off,
watch football,
whatever you want to do.
Then Monday morning you start all over again,
and by next Sunday morning you got to have 25 to 30 minutes of music ready to
perform.
Why is that really hard?
What's the hard part of this?
What's the time consuming part of all of this?
Uh,
I see,
uh,
Roger and Elizabeth or Elizabeth go with him.
Writing it out.
Yeah,
probably not composing it.
I think these composers just have this stuff spewing out of their ears nonstop.
I don't think it was thinking it up and maybe not rehearsing it though.
That would take some time.
But before the days of copyists machines,
uh,
it would be very laborious to copy the full score and all of these parts may be
14 different lines simultaneously and multiple copies of the violin parts and
the cello parts in this.
So it'd be very time consuming.
How did he do this?
Well,
let's see if we can go back to the next slide here.
And we're going to talk about this just for a bit.
How did Bach um,
execute this and the next row row?
I think there was a,
uh,
yeah,
so we're going to go back into our church here and we're going to see box
church,
uh,
where uh,
he is,
um,
uh,
the,
the floor plan here.
And then we're going to next slide,
please
take a look at the inside of it where the sermon was preached and take a note of
the high altar up there.
Next slide.
We're going to go through these quickly now.
Uh,
there we have the west end up there where the Oregon is.
That's where the CANTATA would be performed.
Next slide.
The Oregon up there.
Here's a question for you.
Is this an Oregon from box day?
Next slide
that look like box Oregon,
too many mechanical chemical,
mechanical contrivances there.
So that's an Oregon from the beginning of the 20th century and Box Oregon would
looked far more like this and we're going to talk about this in section a little
bit later on.
Moving on.
Okay,
let's go back to this because this is the building that we saw before the place
where Bach lived.
If we look at it now and start counting up,
we see that nail.
There are five stories before we reach the roof line.
In 1731 buck petition,
the town council because of his large family to take the roof off of this
building and provide him with more space,
more space.
Because he had all of these children,
he had relatives and he had students living in these corridors.
And what did they do to earn their keep?
Well,
they copied music for him.
So this is sort of,
if you will,
the corporate headquarters of Bach Inc.
This is where all this great music is being generated from his wife and am I
Galena?
Bach was his principle a copyist.
All right,
so that's uh,
that's what,
uh,
where they live.
Now,
Bach of course has mentioned died in 1750.
A historians are profoundly grateful to him for that because it gives us a nice
clean cutoff by which to end.
The Baroque era and of Bach and of baroque died in 1750 of a stroke at age 65.
At the time,
he wasn't thought to be particularly important.
So they relegated box remains to an outlying parish church.
As Mozart Played Bach,
Beethoven Played Bach,
Felix Mendelssohn played Bach.
People began to realize that Lo and behold,
they'd had a genius in their midst.
So they x whom Bob to see if he was a genius.
Let's take a look at this.
This is what they did in 1895 they dug him up and they photographed him because
this was the period in which there was a theory of genius.
Interestingly enough,
that the genius had a smaller brain then the normal human being,
not a larger brain,
but a smaller brain.
Uh,
in any event,
Bach's brain turned out to be just completely normal,
and this was presumably a lot of nonsense.
But when they dug him up,
then they repositioned him and they repositioned him at the high altar.
And this marker here is now where the remains of Bach are situated and they tore
out the south side Bank of glass in the church and constructed based on the
photograph that you saw at the beginning of our hour,
that photograph,
um,
uh,
they constructed stained glass windows with titles of some of box works there so
that the musical tourists such as myself or I hope you someday we'll go to
Leipzig.
Uh,
to,
uh,
enjoy the wonderful music of this city and the wonderful music of Bach.
Now,
the last thing we're going to do on our way out the way the cantata within is
that the entire congregation would stand up and everybody together would sing
the corral tune.
We're not going to do that because you already did that.
Uh,
but we'll just play this music as you go out to give you a sense of how the
service would end.
[inaudible]
yeah.